>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> We have a special guest
with us tonight Sam Wineburg.
And I'm going to turn things over to
the director of education outreach here
at the Library of Congress Lee Ann Potter
to welcome you and to introduce our speaker.
>> Thanks very much, Cathy.
As Cathy said, we really are so glad all of you
could join us this evening for this the Library
of Congress's first online conference.
It is my pleasure to be serving as the MC
for this session entitled
"Reading Like a Historian."
During this session for about
the next 50 minutes,
we will explore the Stanford history education
group's reading like a historian curriculum
and the research behind this
free online resource.
You will have an opportunity to examine
a sample lesson plan and consider how
to implement these materials in your classroom.
I'm really pleased to introduce
a good friend Sam Wineburg.
Sam is the Margaret Jacks professor
of education and professor of history
by courtesy at Stanford University.
He leads the Stanford history education group,
the teaching with primary sources program
at Stanford University, Stanford's
Ph.D. program in history education,
and the master's program
for future history teachers.
His scholarship has been featured in the New
York Times, the Washington Post, USA Today,
the New Yorker, as well as on NPR and C-SPAN.
Delighted to have you here, Sam.
Let's get started.
>> My name is Sam Wineburg and thank you
very much Lee Ann for the introduction.
And Cathy for setting this up.
And welcome to all of you who
are joining in here today.
I want to spend the next hour with
you or so, with time for questions,
talking about the question
of historical literacy.
What it is and what it is not.
And I want to begin actually by
telling you about a textbook.
A textbook called "Our Virginia" which
was published and went into classrooms
in the state of Virginia in October of 2010.
Now, this is a -- a textbook that was
intend for fifth graders and in it --
in the story that it tells about the
Civil War it contains this statement.
Thousands of southern blacks
fought in the confederate ranks,
including two black battalions under
the command of Stonewall Jackson.
Now, if you know a little bit about your --
your Civil War history, you might
be a bit surprised by this claim.
If you know about the role, for instance,
of African-Americans in the Civil War.
You might know if you've seen the movie "Glory."
The story of the Massachusetts 54th
which was the first black
division to join the union ranks.
It was a -- a topic of considerable
debate among union soldiers.
By the end of the civil war, there were about
180,000 African-Americans who were suited
up in -- for the forces of the union.
But the notion of southern blacks fighting
for the confederates under Stonewall Jackson
that might be a claim that
you're unfamiliar with.
Now, if we look at this claim, we know
that Thomas Stonewall Jackson
actually died on May 10th 1863.
He was killed by friendly fire.
So, this is still right near the apex
of the fighting in the civil war.
The tide has not yet quite turned.
And if there are two black
battalions under Stonewall Jackson,
we can imagine that there were
many other under other generals.
And if we do our math, well, two --
two battalions that means
a whole bunch of regiments.
It means -- it means tens of thousands of
African-Americans who were suited up in uniform
under the command of Stonewall Jackson
essentially fighting for the confederacy.
So, here's -- here's what we do know.
We do know, of course, that
there were African-Americans,
slaves often who had no choice.
Who were brought into the confederate
army as cooks or as laborers.
We even know of cases and we can find them
documented sometimes with photographic evidence
of slaves who were suited up and accompanied
-- often under duress, often forced and pressed
into service -- who accompanied
their masters into battle.
So, here is a picture of one of the -- the
pictures that we have of a case like that.
But that's not quite what we're
talking about with this claim.
We are talking about the -- the historical
basis of a claim that there were thousands
of African-Americans who were armed who
actually fought on behalf of the confederacy.
And we can ask, what exactly
were they fighting for?
Fighting for the right to remain slaves?
I mean, it becomes a bit ludicrous.
Fighting for the right to have
their children go into slavery?
I mean, the -- the very claim
strains the imagination.
Now, when we look at the documentary evidence
for this claim, when we look in the vast trove
of documents that constitutes the documentary
record, the only documentary evidence we have
of the notion of bringing African-Americans
and suiting them up and arming them
for the confederacy is general
orders, number 14.
And you can see from -- from this in the
section that is highlighted in yellow.
[pause] And you'll also note the
date of this particular document.
Which is March 23red 1865.
Now, this is in the waning
days of the civil war.
It's clear that the south is losing.
It's just a matter of time
before general Lee decides
that he will sign the surrender
-- the surrender of orders.
In fact, this is less than a
month away from the signing
of those surrender orders on
April 9th 1865 at Appomattox.
This is the only document that
we have of African-American --
of the talk of the confederacy drafting
African-American soldiers and suiting them up
and giving them arms and actually fighting.
So, the question becomes, In this textbook that
was given to children in the state of Virginia,
where did the author find the
basis for the claim that she makes?
And when she was asked about it by a reporter
for The Washington Post she responded,
As controversial as it is,
I stand by what I write.
I am a fairly respected author -- excuse me.
I am a fairly respected writer.
And this is how the author responded.
Now, the Washington Post reporter
actually pressed on and tried to find
out on what basis did -- did
Miss Masoff make these claims
that there were organized regiments,
that there were hundreds --
that were 50 to 60,000 African-American
soldiers fighting on behalf of the civil war.
When she was asked how she would
document this claim, she said that she --
she reported that she did
her research on the internet.
And when she was asked where she
went to find her information,
she pointed reporters to this website.
The sons of confederate veterans,
which is a patriotic, historical,
educational institution founded in 1896,
dedicated to honoring the sacrifices
of the confederate soldier and
to preserving southern culture.
This is the situation that we face today.
And I am sure that many of you are facing
situations where your students come to you
and say, well, I Googled it and
I found this on the internet.
Now, when I grew up -- and I'm
sure when many of you grew up --
before historical information reached us, it
had actually been vetted through the hands
of subject matter experts and publishers
and newspaper editors and the various kinds
of people who checked information
before it reached our hands.
But we are actually living in a
time when those kinds of skills
of vetting information actually fall on
the shoulders of each and every one of us.
I don't think that -- that the author of this
textbook is all together different from the --
from facing the kinds of dilemmas that we
face in a totally new digital wild west.
Now, I want to return to this
question of historical literacy.
Because for many people -- for many people,
the notion of historical literacy at least
as it is taught in schools
resembles something like this.
[pause] Now, this actually is an artifact from
a real middle school social studies classroom.
I am not going to tell you where.
I am going to tell you that
it is cut off at 28 items.
It actually goes to 50.
And the way that this classroom went was that
on Monday the teacher would hand out a list
of terms to the middle school students.
And on Friday they would
have a quiz on these terms.
And I happened to be visiting
this classroom to try
to understand what does social studies class
look like through the eyes of seventh graders.
And so I kind of went up to one table
where there were a group of girls working.
They were all girls.
And I said, well, what are you doing?
And they said, we are studying
for our Friday quiz.
And so I asked them if I could peer at this list
that went from acropolis to crusades to czar
to diaspora to ethics and feudalism
and to filial piety, et cetera.
And I said to the young girls -- I
said, well, what exactly is this?
And they kind of grumbled
and laughed to each other.
And then one of the little girls whispered
to me and said, sir, it's traxoline.
And I said, excuse me?
And she said, sir, it's traxoline.
Now, I wonder how many of you who
are listening to me today would find
that answer a little bit quizzical.
What --
[ Pause ]
>> Okay. This is Cathy.
I'm sorry to interrupt, Sam.
I'm sorry to interrupt but we had some
audio issues and now you're back on.
So, I'm going to -- I'm going
to mute myself again.
Thank you.
>> I apologize.
What is traxoline?
Well, let me ask you if you can -- if you
can respond to that because I didn't know.
And so in order for you to essentially test
you as really good students of social studies
in the eyes of this young girl, I am going to
now teach you a short lesson about traxoline.
So, is everyone ready?
Okay. Pay close attention.
It is very important that
you learn about traxoline.
Traxoline is a new form of zionter.
It is montilled in Ceristana.
There's Ceristanians gristerlate
large amounts of fevron
and then bracter it to quasel traxoline.
Traxoline is important because
of our zionter lesidge.
Okay, folks.
Let me ask you this and you
can type your answer.
What is traxoline?
I'll wait a second.
[ Pause ]
Indeed, traxoline is a form of zionter.
Thank you very much.
Now, the questions are going
to get a little bit harder.
Where is traxoline montilled?
[pause] Unbelievable.
I'm looking at your answers.
You're doing great.
Ceristana, absolutely correct.
However, those of you who are familiar
with Bloom's taxonomy should be
ready for a higher-order question.
A question that requires some
application and some synthesis.
And now I'm going to ask you a
question about where you're going
to have to make a bit of an inference.
Why is traxoline important?
I'll wait.
Put your thinking caps on.
There we go.
Because of our zionter lesidge.
Now, this was the situation that this
young 11-year-old explained to me.
This is -- this is how she
described the kind of meaning --
the meanings of the words
in her social studies class.
The words serf and hajj and schism and
heretic and plebeian and oligarchy made
about as much sense as traxoline,
gristerlate, zionter, and lesidge.
This notion of -- of disembodied facts
that kids can define unfortunately
in many ways still defines our
ideas about historical literacy.
And we need to go no farther than the headlines
of our major newspapers when a new study
about student's knowledge comes out.
This one is actually from May 12th 2002.
Kids get an abysmal grade in history.
High school seniors don't know basic facts.
And actually if we were to
go nearly 10 years later,
we could read virtually the same exact headline.
Students stumble again on the basics of history.
National test shows little progress.
And we will get exactly the same
headlines in the 2014 administration
of the national assessment
of educational progress.
Over and over again we talk about the
dismal or abysmal knowledge of our student.
That, if we go back to the first large scale
test of historical facts which was done in 1917
in Texas where less than 10% of
the population actually went --
made it to high school, we will hear
the same kinds of complaints then.
But let's change course a little bit.
Let's talk about the assumptions
behind these kinds of headlines
and the assumptions behind the kinds
of tests that we give to young people.
So, what is the assumption?
The assumption is that if kids
had lots of names and dates.
If they were historically literate, if you
will, they would be able to think historically.
And so I want to talk about this assumption for
a second with you by recounting a bit of history
that you may or may not be familiar with.
So, let's go to the dawn
of the American revolution.
A very famous event.
The shot heard 'round the world.
The battle of Lexington.
April 19th 1775.
Take a look at this picture and think
about how you would describe some
of the things that you see in it.
[ Pause ]
What is it that you notice?
Now, if you compare this painting to another
image -- I'm seeing some of your answers.
Lots of smoke.
People who are injured.
A defiant man.
Someone is interpreting the
-- the minute man in the front
with an outstretched arm as saying something.
Who knows what he's saying.
We don't have a tape recording.
Maybe saying, our colors don't run.
Well, that would be an anachronistic since
we didn't have colors yet at that point.
These men still saw themselves
as British subjects.
Let me give you another rendition
of this same event.
A different illustration of it.
What do you see in this picture?
[ Pause ]
Now, one of the questions we would
want to ask -- and I'm -- I'm --
I'll read aloud some of the answers that
you're seeing in your -- in your chat boxes.
The colonists are victims.
This is a slaughter.
This is not the battle of Lexington.
This is the massacre at Lexington.
In fact, if you were to take a magnifying
glass to this second illustration
which was actually a wood
cut done about -- done --
a lithograph done by amos doolittle about a
month after the actual battle in -- in 1775.
If you took a magnifying glass -- at --
of it, you would see not a single one
of the minute men actually holding a
firearm and taking aim at the British.
They are all hastily beating a
retreat from the battlefield.
Now, how do we know what is true?
What -- what -- how would we
-- here we are probably one
of the most -- the shot heard 'round the world.
Two different illustrations.
We might want to ask, what are the circumstances
of each one of these illustrations?
I'll go back to the first one for a second.
This picture was actually done in
1886 for very different purposes.
And this was done in 1775 for
also very different purposes.
And yet when we commemorate
ourselves as a people that --
and we choose an illustration to commemorate
this event actually 150 years after the event
with a U.S. postage stamp -- it is
not this one that we choose to put
on the postage stamp but the former.
This is the way that we choose as a people
to represent ourselves to ourselves.
But immediately we are thrown
into the abyss of historiography.
How do we know what happened in the past?
Here are two different perspectives.
We can get a variety of original sources
that disagree about what happened.
Was this a group of colonists standing
tall representing what would become the
American spirit?
Or were these a group of very
scared British subjects getting off
of the Lexington green as soon as they could?
As soon as firing started?
Now, I wanted to actually look at how some
of the successes of our educational system --
not the students who do poorly on these factual
tests but students who do quite well do on them.
And so I selected a group of students
who had completed an AP history course,
had very high reading scores on the
SAT, who knew a great deal of history.
And I compared them to a group of historians.
And I am here to tell you, as a kind of example
of what research and education is all about,
the chief finding of this research was
that the historians did much better
on this task adjudicating among
these two different paintings.
Looking and ferreting out
the discrepancies among seven
or eight fragmented primary sources
many of them which you can find
in the Library of Congress's collection.
The historians did much better in
creating a sound historical interpretation
than the high school students.
Now, if I could see the facial
reaction of many of you,
some of you might be scratching your head.
You might be saying to yourself, um.
Okay. The historians did better.
Um. So, that's -- that's what you want to say?
The historians did better?
Now, if you are quizzical and you are asking
yourself that question, then I would ask you
to answer the question, why do you
think the historians did better?
And you might respond by saying, well,
the historians did better
because they're historians.
After all, they're -- they're historians.
Well, if you have taken a college philosophy
course, philosophy 101, you know the statement
that historians did better because they
are historians is what philosophers call
a tautology.
It's like saying sleeping pills work
because of their dormative properties.
It is a case of circular reasoning.
You -- you might then say that historians
did better because they're better readers.
Well, again, I took really the cream of
the cream of our high school students.
You might say that historians do
better because they know more history.
That's -- that's sort of what defines them.
Well, here's what I did.
Here's the wrinkle that I threw
into this -- this little project.
I gave a quiz to historians.
Questions from the chapter review
tests at that point of "Rise
of the American nation," Todd, Curti.
It was reading -- U.S. history textbook for
the eleventh grade when I did this work.
And here are some of the kinds
of facts that were on this quiz.
Virtual representation, olive branch
petition, identify George Grenville,
internal versus external
taxation, the Quebec act.
And I chose only dumb historians.
I choose -- chose historians who were
not specialists in American history.
And I chose students who had done very well.
In fact, had earned a grade of three and
above on the AP U.S. history exam who were
in many ways the poster children for
the successes of our educational system.
Now, what I want to suggest to you that --
is that when the historians and the high
school students looked at the original sources
that I used they saw profoundly
different things.
And I further want to argue that
it was not an issue really of --
of reading level or of knowing
different vocabulary.
It was the very approach to
what a historical text is.
And let me see if I can -- I can demonstrate
that to you by letting you look at the one
of the primary sources that
I used which you will find
in the library of congress's collection.
So, I'm going to make it the next slide and ask
you to spend a minute looking at it as a piece
of primary evidence about this event.
But as you're looking at it, please,
monitor kind of the way that you read.
The way that you approach the document.
What's the first thing that you do?
What do you attend to?
So, I'm going to flash it up and I
want you to kind of be bifocal here.
Look at the content but also try to reflect
on your own approach to this document.
Okay. Are we ready?
Here it is.
[ Pause ]
Okay. We ready?
All right.
So, let me -- let me -- I want to kind of
model for you how one of these students --
very good, very good students --
how they approached this document.
So, I'm going to read a little bit aloud.
And -- and -- and I use a
technique called thinking aloud
where people articulate their
thoughts during the act of reading.
So, let me try to model how one of the
17 year olds -- we'll call her Ellen.
How she -- how she approached this document.
So, she began, 19.
At 2:00 o'clock, we began our march by wading
through a very long ford up to our middle.
She stops.
She says a -- a -- a very long ford.
I don't know what ford means.
Clearly, it's not an automobile.
But we -- wading means going through water
and up to our middle so maybe it's some --
a forward is some kind of body of water.
For those of you who work with adolescents
all day long and perhaps some of you work
with struggling leaders or English
language learners, you know that that kind
of meta cognition, the ability to
step back and infer a word's meaning
from context is an extremely sophisticated skill
that characterizes the reading armamentarium
of our best students, our best
reading comprehenders [phonetic].
She then goes on.
After going a few miles, three or four
people were going out to get intelligence
about five miles out of town called
Lexington which lay on a road.
We heard there were some hundreds of people.
She starts, we heard there were some.
And she says, it -- it sounds
like it was a chaotic situation.
She -- she continues to read, I
believe three -- two to three hundred.
She says, see.
Yes, it was chaotic.
Those of you who were familiar with a reading
technique called "reciprocal teaching" know
that at the heart of reciprocal teaching is
developing students' meta cognition and the use
of prediction in the course of reading.
So, she actually predicts and
then confirms what she reads.
So, again very, very able reading strategies.
She continues to read.
Gets near the bottom.
We then formed on the common
but with some difficult.
And she says, see.
I -- I see a chaotic image in our mind.
The men were so wild they could hear no orders.
Again, a confirmation of the kind
of picture that she's developing.
We waited a considerable time there and
at length proceed on our way to Concord.
And then she'll say entry to April
19th from the [inaudible] Barker.
This is an extremely sophisticated reading with
a lot of antiquated vocabulary by a 17-year-old
who has the kind of reading skills
that we wish for many of our students.
She actually went on to a very prestigious
four-year college and had a lot to go on.
Now, I want to suggest by showing you the
reading of a historian Fred, a medievalist,
who -- who, you know, was -- didn't do too good.
Didn't too well.
Excuse my English.
A -- a pretest on the olive branch
petition and George grenville.
He's a -- a medievalist.
We can give him a little slack.
He -- maybe hasn't made his way all
the way up to the American revolution.
This medievalist looked at the same document,
did much worse on the test of factual knowledge
that presumably is what you
need in order to read critically
and to read in sophisticated ways.
Let's look at the way that
Fred begins his reading.
So, he begins with the same document.
Nineteenth at 2:00 o'clock we
began our march by wading a
through a very long ford up to our middles.
And this is the first thing that he says.
This is the first thing that
comes out of his mouth.
Dire [phonetic] of John Marker,
British, an officer, 19th.
That's the day itself.
So, I want you to think for a second
what it is that Fred has done?
What is it that he has done that
profoundly distinguishes his --
his reading from the way that these very bright
high school students approach this document?
[ Pause ]
I see a lot of answers.
You are answering in -- in a lovely way
but I want you to think behaviorally.
I want you to really go -- explain this
on the level of what are his eyes doing,
what exactly is he doing with his
eyes that is so deceptively simple and
yet so profoundly different from
what the high school students do.
[ Pause ]
So, yes, I see someone -- he goes
to the bottom of the document.
So, on a pure behavioral level, he
goes to the bottom of the document.
But -- but how do you explain -- what
does he mean, That's the day, itself?
What the heck is he talking about?
Nineteenth.
That's the day, itself?
We have to go into these details for you to
understand the depth and the sophistication
of what appears to be a very simple move.
Yes, he knows the date of the battle and
indeed he's writing it on the same day.
Now, I want you to give this document to
your students tomorrow without any kind
of preparation and see if any single student
in the class even make the suggestion
that by putting 19th at the top of a
diary entry does not necessarily mean
that it was written on the 19th.
It could've been written on the 27th.
It could've been written on the 28th.
It could've been actually after
all kinds of hell broke loose
and he decided he needed to
go back and change his diary.
But this is the way the historian starts to
think about the nature of historical evidence.
Now, then he does something
that I do not believe that if --
unless you've taught your student this way.
[ Inaudible speakers ]
So, here's what I want you to do tomorrow.
Give your students this document and see
if any of them do what Fred does here.
He continues.
He reads the document once
through making a few comment.
And then he makes this comment.
We all know about diaries.
Nineteenth.
He wrote it on that day.
Maybe. Cover his back side.
Better that he lost control over his
men than to have ordered the first shot.
Useful in an inquest.
He was a Berkeley historian.
What were they smoking in Berkeley?
There's nothing in this document
about an inquest.
There's not -- yet Fred has a
fundamentally different relation
to historical evidence than
our high school students.
Our high school students are looking
at primary sources almost as if --
as if they were baskets of
information to be mastered and memorized
to be repeated on a multiple choice test.
For Fred, these documents are not inanimate.
They are people.
And before he can understand what is in a
document, he has to know to whom he is speaking.
This is why we use primary
sources in the classroom.
This is why we go to the library of
congress and examine these sources.
Because we hear the voices of real
human beings who actually made the past.
And for kids to resurrect these voices, to
actually hear them is fundamentally different
from the kind of socialization that we put
them through with 14,000 hours in school
where they look at anything
having to do with history as,
will I need to know this for the test?
Now, I want to end -- I'm going to jump
through a few slides because our time is short.
And I just want to quickly talk about -- I'm
going to skip a bit and talk about trying
out this approach in -- in a
large city school district.
And about four years ago San Francisco
asked us largely because of issues of --
of literacy and wanting -- wanting
to use and marshal the resources
of social studies to help students' literacy.
They asked us to come in with
this approach and actually take
over the eleventh grade curriculum
in several high schools.
And we did what in research terms is
called a "treatment control study."
This was done by my Ph.D. student Avishag --
Abby Reisman who's now an assistant professor
at the university of Pennsylvania and with --
with just indomitable energy she went into
San Francisco and working with a group
of teachers taught history in this approach
starting with legitimate historical questions.
Central historical questions.
Providing some background.
The evaluation of evidence
and whole class discussions.
Now, I'm going to cut to the chase
and show you the kind of thing that --
that very much excited the district.
We had different kinds of assessment.
The district was very interested
in this assessment.
And you -- the [inaudible] comprehension test.
And low and bond when students in their social
studies classrooms are looking carefully
at primary source documents and
learning to read in a very careful way
like this -- this predates the common core.
We like to say we were common
before the common core.
There is a significant effect
for reading level for students
in this -- in these kinds of classrooms.
Since then, we have become, for instance,
the -- the social studies curriculum and --
and LA unified, the second
largest district in the country.
I can tell you a great deal about this research
but I'm going to now share with you this video.
Shows the power of primary
sources and inquiry of learning.
>> I remember they, like, last year -- last year
our first year of history and I did not like it
because they would just give us a textbook.
When it comes to this year,
it was more like, wow.
We get documents.
Like, I never seen that before.
Like, a teacher giving me documents?
>> The reading like a historian project turns
the traditional history classroom on its head.
Rather than focusing on the passive retention of
names and dates, this approach invites students
to become historical investigators
using the skills of historians
to answer questions about the past.
Each class is organized around a
legitimate historical question.
Students explore these questions by going
back to the sources encountering the voices
of historical actors in original documents.
>> There's usually some kind
of intro lecture or, you know,
giving students the background information,
setting the stage for what they might not know.
And then typically it poses
the question for the day.
Is the question for the day,
was the new deal a success?
was Lincoln a racist?
>> Is the image of the happy
1950s housewife accurate?
I want you to show me the evidence that
leads you to believe that's your answer.
[inaudible speaker]
>> Like where?
Document c.
>> I never really done that before.
Like, getting the chance to agree
and disagree with what we study.
It helps to get deeper in
what you're learning about.
>> We have a crucial problem of
literacy in our nation's urban schools.
And the moment this approach goes into a school,
what we automatically do is we double the amount
of time that kids are exposed to texts.
>> I believe that their reading
is improving at least as much
as their ability to analyze documents.
I think this constant knowing when you
walk in the door we are reading today.
And we are not just putting
our eyes on the page and hoping
that the bell rings before
anybody asks us a question.
But we're reading and then
we're talking about it.
>> Ninety-six percent in document d
of women married reported they were
either extremely happy or fairly happy.
>> We have document a. What's the
first thing we're going to do?
>> [students respond] Source.
>> Teachers trained in the approach were matched
with teachers in regular history classrooms.
At the end of the year, students were
assessed on their historical thinking ability,
their mastery of factual knowledge, and their
growth in general reading comprehension.
>> What we found was that not only did students
in the treatment classes and the reading
like historian classes do better on
historical thinking and on the retention
of historical facts but also they
grew in reading comprehension.
>> Now I know history like boom, boom, boom.
Like this now.
It's kind of easier.
And, like, I know certain dates.
Kind of weird and everything.
But I know certain dates like better now.
>> I was absolutely into nurturing them so
that they would never be made too feel badly
because they didn't have good reading skills.
And I took very good care of them.
And I didn't teach them how to read anything.
>> Now that I see that there's a difference
between making somebody feel better
about themselves for no good reason and
giving them the skills to be able to do better
in their lives and be more
powerful in their own lives.
Right? That's what I think this program has
done for me as a teacher because I'm able
to see them actually do so much better.
>> I read more thoroughly and more,
like, detail to certain parts.
I look for certain things right away.
>> And so far this is my favorite history class.
I really mean it.
It's not boring.
It's fun. I learn many things.
I wish there was, like, a better -- like,
for next year, for senior year, like,
same history class but learning more things
because I feel like there's more to learn.
A lot more.
>> Thank you very much.
Again, some people have seen the
video and some people haven't.
Take a look at it at your time but I am here
for you at least for the next seven minutes
to answer your questions about our approach.
>> I was noticing when I
was on the YouTube video
that there were quite a few
additional videos produced
by the Stanford history education group.
Do you want to describe what some of those are
because I have a feeling this group
may be particularly interested in them.
>> Sure. There -- we -- we have quite
a few videos of -- if you go to the --
our main web page -- the [inaudible].edu And
Joel [inaudible] if you're going to listen
to that webinar as well we'll tell you
more about how to use different kinds
of assessments in the history classroom.
But I think my experience in working with
groups of teachers who are not familiar
with this approach the most useful
thing from our experience has been
to see teachers actually teaching in these
ways in some very difficult urban settings.
In some settings that where students may be
in 11th grade but are not reading at grade.
What do you do?
And so the teaching channel --
teachingchannel.org has produced a
50-minute special in various classrooms
that are using our reading
like a historian approach.
And if you go to the History
Channel and register,
it's completely -- the registration is free.
You will see a series of about five
or six videotapes that together come
to about 50 minutes of footage of
different teachers in different kinds
of classrooms using this
approach with real students
in high school and middle school classrooms.
So, you'll want to check that
out on the teachingchannel.org.
Just type in for the search,
reading like a historian.
There was a question here.
Is -- is the Stanford history education group
continuing to come out with lesson plans?
The answer is absolutely yes.
We are expanding our resources particularly
for the teaching of middle school world history
and ancient civilizations as well as the
high school world history curriculum.
And we are continuing again
within our capacity to --
to produce new materials to be responsive
to the needs that you expressed.
We depend upon you.
We hope you will follow us.
We hope you will write to us.
We hope you will use our materials.
All of our materials are free.
It costs nothing to download.
There is no curriculum to buy.
All of the materials that we have
on our website are completely free.
All you have to do is register and you
can download to your heart's delight.
[pause] Are there -- there's a question
of could you recommend resources
to assist elementary school teachers?
Well, I would say one thing to do
is to follow Lee Ann Potter's column
in social education every
month that it comes out.
To become a member of the national
council for the social studies.
There are a variety of good resources for
the elementary social studies curriculum.
There's a website called "bringing history
home" done at the university of Iowa
which is extraordinary in terms of helping
fourth and fifth graders think both
to develop their literacy skills as well as
to develop their historical thinking skills.
There's a question.
Do you find it hard to get kids reading?
Yes. Increasingly, it is hard
to -- to -- to get kids to read.
It's one of the reasons why our
primary sources are extremely short.
So, give an eighth grader or even
an 11th grader reading at a --
at a normal grade level a dense page of tightly
packed text in 10-point type is intimidating.
I can tell you that it's
intimidating for the students I teach
as 18-year-olds at Stanford university.
The reason that we work with primary
sources in the classroom is not
to expose students to copious amounts of texts.
It's to teach them to read slowly
and to really read closely.
And the longer and the more
dense a text is the more you --
the more you defeat the purpose of
reading carefully and reading closely.
So, yes, it's difficult.
And students don't spontaneously come
to us knowing how to read this way.
The best and most important piece of curriculum
that you have at your disposal is your own self
and modeling for students how you think
about text and how you read this way.
Without a clear adult model
of how you read, it's --
you can bet that many students will not develop
the kind of reading skills that you want them
to develop in order to be
sophisticated, informed citizens.
>> Thank you, Sam.
This Cathy.
I'm going to leave you with Tim's question
as the last question of the evening
and Amber sent in a more complex question.
And we'll make sure that we
get that to you in the chat.
You can follow Sam at Sam
Wineburg and his website
for the Stanford education
group is up on the slide.
I'm going to leave you with the last question.
Then I'm going to advance to the
last slide which is some information
about getting certificate of completion.
Plus a link to a three-question
survey that we'd like to ask our --
our folks to fill out before they leave.
We do have to end this session
in about two minutes.
But Tim's question is, how long does it
typically take to get kids up to speed
and comfortable with these types of sources?
>> That's a really good question, Tim.
It -- it takes a while.
Because we've done a number on kids.
Right? We -- we have tested them to death.
We've tested them with traxoline-like tests.
And so the -- the consequences of our own fruits
is the attitude that many students display
which is, well, just tell me the answer.
And so for students to unlearn that
is not a one- or two-lesson issue.
It is something that we have to
stay the course and do regularly.
And we have to show them how
applicable it is to their everyday life.
I hope you will see the connections between
the kinds of questions that we're asking
about historical evidence and the very way
that information comes to us in a digital age.
If we do not ask who made a website,
who is telling us this information,
why are they telling it to us.
Is it -- is it sponsored?
Is it sponsored content which is a --
a euphemism for an ad that actually
masquerades as a news story?
These kinds of questions might have been in a --
in a previous age something that maybe only the
elite students had to -- had to think about.
In the digital age that we live
where all information comes to us,
where there are no people who are vetting what
comes us on the web as we saw from the example
of the textbook "our Virginia," these are
the kinds of ways of thinking and the ways
of knowing that have to be the inheritance,
that have to be in the possession
of every single informed citizen that we want
to send out to the world in our classrooms.
So, I think my time is actually up.
Thank you very much [inaudible
speaker] And be sure to contact us.
Take care.
I really enjoyed your questions.
>> Thank you very much, Sam.
This has been a very enriching for all of us.
I thank you for your time.
And I thank you all for your attendance.
I will make sure that this
chat gets to Sam Wineburg
so that he can take a look
at your in-depth questions.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to end the recording
and end the meeting.
Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.